hello everyone sorry about only one
video yesterday and I didn't even think
I would manage to do one video today
because yesterday I had a tournament
game also I had a tournament game today
yesterday I lost against an
international master from Bosnia and
today I won a game against ok candidate
master in the game I lost I played like
really really passive and my opponent
punished me so it was well deserved and
in the game I won I was I think overly
active even even more actually than I
should have been but in the end it all
worked out so I'll probably show both of
these games but like I said I wasn't
planning on doing a video today but I
saw a lot of you said do video on the
vs. grace joke and I said okay I'm gonna
check out this game as I was playing the
tournament I couldn't really follow the
Talz memorial that was being played from
2nd to 4th of March but then I saw the
game and I said ok I definitely have to
do this game today as we shortened won't
ozma Morial and this game is it's really
like you know reminds you of the style
of Michael Tao so it would be ashamed
not and not to show it so unearned opens
with E 4 and we have C 5 by 3 shook the
Sicilian defence Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 and now Bishop to b5 the raw SoLoMo
attack also sometimes called the Dinesh
Medina attack g6 we have Bishop captures
D captures on c6 and now d3 Bishop to g7
we have h3 not allowing Bishop to g4
Knight to f6 now Knight to c3 castles we
have Bishop to b3 b6 Queen d2 preparing
Queen to Bishop to h6 e 5 and now B
mediate Bishop to h6 and so far all is
well on the board Queen to b6 developing
the Queen ready to develop the light
square bishop and connect rooks we have
wins at castle now comes a 5 and G for a
for King to b1 and Bishop to e6 now here
are none plays Knight to e2 his
rhe maneuvering tonight the g3 and then
depending on what my place to either f5
or h5 if if possible so we have b5 Allen
goes night the g3 and now rook F to d8
Bishop captures on g7 king captors on g7
and now Queen to g5 now you can see that
Knight to f5 is already a threat as the
G pawn is pinned
we have 937 here black black is
preparing to push f6 for example if
white would continue with something slow
like h4 Adam black can simply play f6
kicking away the Queen after the Queen
moves now he can capture the pawn here
and after white continues with his
attack simply rook to h8 and black black
is defending
so after this Knight to d7 move Anand
went for the immediate Knight to f5
discounts with check checks the King
also forms the Queen so you do have to
capture the night you have to capture
with the bishop as the geophone is
pinned so Bishop captures now G captures
on f5 and here we had a 3 so how do you
continue now of course first b3 and we
had h6 now giving away islands Queen
Queen to g3 and here again you have to
do something to prevent white from
attacking with black you can't really
lock the position with g5 because white
will simply push h4 and why kiss a white
is breaking through here even would have
sex you can simply capture capture and
even capture now with the knight on d5
pawn captures Queen captures and you're
getting checkmated here King goes rogue
check King of 7 Queen h5 check king
moves king rock to h7 check King moves
and Queen to f7 it's a forced checkmate
so after this Queen to G to remove
grease chip decided to go King to h7
Anand plays rook H 2 G 1 now I'm not
allowing this trip to to capture on f5
we have Queen to f6 and now comes h4 and
now G captures on h5 on f5 and now you
can't capture here with some idea of
captures captures and checkmate
although black can always go up to g8
but just you know for 4
showing black has this efore move and
then you lose a piece Unitas attacked
and there's the threat of going to g2
checkmate
so black does have this resource if
white isn't careful so uh none place
Queen to h3 and now we have f4 and rook
to g5 and you can't of course captured
rook if you capture it you lose the
Queen after eight chapters on g5 so
Grisha played Queen to e6 and now what
do you do here Grichuk is attacking
announced Queen here on h3 so on simply
blocks of rock to f5 we have Knight rope
to g8 now and this is a this is actually
the mistake that cost a very stupid game
here he has to play f6 f6 is an
essential move here it prevents this
rook from making any useful discoveries
on the Queen and also now both hng and
f1 are guarding the g5 square and the
Grichuk missed our next move so
otherwise he definitely would have
played it f6 but he played rock to g8
and it's a very nice very nice position
for you to solve you aren't here
feel free to beat district pause the
video you know find the solution and
don't like if you found the mu don't
think you've solved it immediately maybe
try to find it you know all the way so I
will give it a couple of seconds as
always so for those of you who were able
to solve this congratulations you are an
excellent player and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show here on
and played Knight to g5 check so what do
you do here
the king is in check the queen is also
attacked so you do have to capture the
night we had H captures on g5 and here
if you found H capture some g5 then you
would not be beating Greece shook as now
black can simply defend King g7 and now
you have no way of actually continuing
this attack if you go rogue to h1 to try
and do something then King simply
escapes and if you try something like
Queen h6 check captures captures King
can capture and there's no real way for
white to gain any advantage
here you can capture but black and
simply block and black will always be up
a piece
so after this Knight to g5 check that
was a good move if you found it H
captures but now not capturing and g5
immediately
but first rook captures and f7 / - check
and now black is completely lost
now Anand is attacking districts Queen
on e6 also the king is in check so you
either have to move the King and then
lose the Queen or you have to capture
the rope so deletion captured it and now
comes H capture some g5 would have
discovered check but now it's completely
different as black can either give up
the Queen with Queen to h5 or he can
play King to g6 or King to g g7 or g6
doesn't even matter whatever black plays
Bishop played King to g7 and now comes
Queen to h6
and this is checkmate the Queen and rook
are blocking any escape the black King
might have so that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it and what a way for under
the the reigning rapid world champion to
win such a strong tournament like tiles
memorial and I do have here a photo of
the final position here Grisha is
congratulating honor on his win you have
the you see the Queen on h6 the black
king is in checkmate and you can see by
the time on the clock undone finish the
game with four minutes and 46 seconds
and the grace chick only had 43 seconds
so you know Anand is like really fast
and not only this I also have for you a
photo of the final standings of this
tournament as you can see it was it was
a pretty close tournament Anand won it
with six are nine four wins one loss and
four draws his only loss was against
shockwave Maduro in round three then
mama dro in second place correctly
Nakamura Alden with five points than
Grisha can get funded with four and a
half
cranly can do both with four and then
the pony ahsha and swiller with three
and a half points so an extremely strong
tournament I believe the average yellow
rating of the tournament was over twenty
seven hundred and fifty so you know it's
but and is the world
rapid reigning Chess Champion so it's
not really not really a surprise good
for him
so yeah I do hope you enjoyed it
tomorrow I will see if I will be all
ready with my tablet winning series or
first maybe I will show my two games
from the tournament we'll see how it
goes
I would like to thank Jake that was for
a contribution to my channel thank a lot
to really appreciate it as usual you can
check to my previous videos here thank
you for watching and I will see you soon
and have a great rest of the Sunday